RFK Junior's primary challenge to
President Biden causing some Panic for
the White House and Democrats there's
worry that Kennedy's Rising profile and
decent poll numbers could be stealing
some of Biden's re-election funder a
Democrat strategist thinks the President
should quote take RFK seriously Biden if
you don't we can create a stronger
Republican party that beats Us in 2024
Like Bernie did in 2016 RFK has the
potential to activate Fringe anger if we
mock them and just this week the
Democratic candidates showing up at the
border
this is a humanitarian crisis because of
the understanding across the globe that
we now have an open border here
there are people being drawn here
they're being abused there are there is
all kinds of desert horrific
a terrible terrible stories and this is
not a good thing for our country it's
not a good thing for these people and it
is unsustainable
RFK going where Biden does not dare To
Tread oh man I love this story so much
Democrats who call him Fringe call him
Fringe because moderates are now The
Fringe he when you listen to his
interviews and I wish people would he
rejects the prison of two ideas he wants
to move past the US versus them
mentality this is something that Biden
had actually weaponized he pits people
against each other this guy wants to get
away from that he's persuasive enough to
make make you revisit your stances and I
know some people you have to you have to
uh
you have to call out the elephant in the
room his voice you know how can you win
with a voice like that well easy because
he forces you to listen to him think
about how Joe Biden sounds so Breezy and
effervescent and says nonsense just
nonsense this guy struggles to speak and
every single word he says matters
Democrats shouldn't be jittery they
should be joyful they should hope Joe
Biden steps down and this guy becomes
their nominee because he could beat
Trump trump is a brilliant debater he's
an attack dog he feeds off anger anger
is his energy right where is rfk's
energy toward Trump none where is rfk's
energy toward maggot Republicans
supporters none she's the opposite
opposite of Joe Biden he actually likes
the deplorables he condemned that word
he understands blue collars where only
Joe Biden fakes it Joe Biden pretends
he's his Average Joe and he hangs out
with steel workers like he's Chums with
his Panic or you know he knows guy
because he knows the name of his driver
RFK is actually the real deal he goes
out he fishes he explores he reads books
I I can't believe how much I like this
person because I never could stand the
Kennedys but I might have to switch by
part by party just so I could vote for
him in the primary because I honestly do
think he is a serious breath of fresh
air he genuinely sees and feels the
appeal of the Trump supporter and even
Trump himself and that's why that's why
I believe Trump will have a hard time
debating him because he'll agree with
him he'll agree with RFK Jr on the Deep
State on the military industrial complex
on the Unseen and unheard Americans I
mean
I don't know I just think he's this dude
is a Powerhouse be stupid to write him
off Harold Ford Jr would you like to
reply from the Democrat point of view
and he wouldn't ban books I think I
think Greg Greg is Greg is largely right
as is that strategist if you look at
what the strategist reference he
referenced Bernie Sanders in 2016 who I
think
accentuated some of the weaknesses and
shortcomings that even some Democrats
and independents in the midwest felt
about Mrs Clinton if you dismiss him and
I know what they're doing and I know
what they're trying to do is to not give
his campaign more fuel or more
seriousness but you can't dismiss
someone who's going to the Border you
can't dismiss someone who is saying that
what's happening there is unsustainable
now I disagree with Greg about about his
I don't think RFK is a serious a
candidate for president but he's raising
serious issues that deserve I think a
different kind of attention than that's
being given the border and how to your
point Greg I've heard him talk about
middle class America and how the wealthy
in the country the wealthiest in the
country got so much wealthier during
covet and those who were in the middle
their kids didn't get educated they lost
a year at work they lost a bill early to
learn how to work and know how to work
these are issues we have to deal with
and I give them credit for bringing
those issues up and I hope that the
advice I don't know the young man I
think it was a young man that made that
Michael cuss I don't know how to
pronounce it the strategist they're
awesome I hope that I hope the White
House takes it seriously because I think
he's right do you know what else Jesse
we talk a lot about the visuals right
because it's a visual medium and when
it's interesting if you could pull that
back up there when RFK is at the border
he's using a selfie video right so it's
not like some like highly like slick
political ad it's more authentic this is
what Beto O'Rourke wanted to be yeah
exactly oh my gosh and he could never
pull it off I like him a lot but I had
to even invite him from Jesse Waters
prime time because he did every other
show in the universe except my show so
it was just a matter of honor at that
point
Biden is rattled because RFK Juniors
campaigning and Joe Biden is not
campaigning so RFK Jr is not falling
he's not lying he's not hiding he's
actually doing interviews maybe not on
my show but he's traveling he is
engaging I bet you'd see him in the
south side of Chicago you're gonna see
more of him in these venues and it's
going to resonate now he said some very
interesting stuff about the Border he
said he interviewed
150 people they're coming in from West
Africa Afghanistan Nepal
Kazakhstan China all of them are
unvetted they go to the border patrol
agents for like 24 hours and they
process them and they disappear
and they said all of these people are
living tragedies because they've all
been physically abused by Cartel coyotes
and they've all been robbed Blind by the
cartel coyotes so it's a human
catastrophe down there now he's not
Fringe I agree with Greg the man's
pragmatic that makes him Fringe because
he's saying the same things Democrats
have said for many many years defense
contractors are getting boatloads of
money to build weapons that they don't
need and big Tech is censoring us and
big Pharma is in bed with the federal
government and the little guy is getting
screwed if that makes you Fringe then
we're all French Judge Pirro wrap us up
okay you know I think that RFK is giving
the Democrats something that Joe and
Kamala can't and that is a plan that is
a coherent argument that is appealing to
issues that are important to us I mean
him at the border when I saw that I said
good for you now I know him he was in
Westchester for years he's an
environmental guy and and he is a guy
who works hard he is genuine he believes
what he believes and what did the
Kennedy name is a pro uh I don't know I
mean everybody's got an opinion I'm not
a pollster I don't have the slightest
idea but what I know is when he talks
about the immigrants coming into this
country the numbers being unsustainable
the fact that it's a humanitarian crisis
which Kamala can't say it Joe Biden
can't say it this guy is more than an
annoyance to the White House this guy is
a real deal and I'll tell you what he's
not placating he's not gonna he's not
the kind of guy who's gonna say oh you
know um I believe in the assault weapons
ban and uh I I you know I think the
election process is perfect I mean he's
going against some of the Democrat some
of their plans he's not afraid of that I
think that even though he differs in
some fundamental issues with Democrats
as long as he stays on that one cultural
issue abortion with the Democrats they
won't care because they see him as
incredible and I think that those people
who were in the in the pan for Joe Biden
are only in the pan for Joe Biden
because they hate Donald Trump if they
think that there is an alternative to uh
not Donald Trump but an alternative to
Joe they're going to jump in this is a
story that's just beginning I wonder
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now